dann verein nach vorn ich drück mann
nach rechts und nach links aber ich kann
mich auf jeden fall damit fortbewegen
jetzt ist zwar sehr sehr langsam aber es
funktioniert und das ist unglaublich und
das macht ein gewisses mario kart
feeling
hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
fei am dienstag über jeder minecraft
folge wird irgendwo in dieser folge
zwischendurch ein kleines geräusch
eingeblendet und das könnt ihr mir unten
in die kommentare schreiben und dann
werdet ihr eventuell in der nächsten
folge erwähnt von mir aber ich würde
sagen dass wir dann auch sofort mit den
facts anfangen und zwar meint peters der
leber zu mir schreiben zu müssen werde
dankeschön dafür wenn man untote mit
einem heiltrank abwirft werden diese
geschwächt dass sie ganz einfach daran
dass untote sind ja wie der name schon
sagt sind zombies und wenn ich diese
quasi heile dann werden sie wieder
menschen also ich kann hier ist mein
bisschen
keiner mehr da der zweite effekt kommt
auch von karriere und zwar ist der sehr
sehr geil ich bin sehr sehr cool wird
mit mir des öfteren zugesendet an meine
mail contractor gmail.com kontrast
gmail.com da könnt ihr im effekt
entsteht auch in der beschreibung wenn
effekt gehabt aber nur cool effect bitte
weil die serie ist cool ich bin cool ihr
seid cool sind für das ganze nicht
passen ebenfalls meinte er zu mir es ist
scheißegal ob ich so einen repeater
nehme also der auf die erste stufe
eingestellt ist auf die zweite oder auf
die dritte oder vierte das ist relativ
egal
und es ist auch egal ob ich einen
normalen amboss nehmen leicht
beschädigen oder einen sehr beschädigten
einen stark beschädigten amboss nehme
wenn ich diese runterfallen lassen auf
einen repeater verschwinden die repeater
einfach etwas hier passiert ist weiß ich
gerade gar nicht aber die übeltäter
verschwinden einfach das ist richtig
krass also wenn ich quasi einfach den
repeater nehme das ist krass das ist
krass bei einem stark beschädigten von
der höhe geht es wahrscheinlich nicht
aber hier verschwinden die repeater
einfach ich ganz gerne mal ganz kurz
zeigen indem ich einfach nochmal den
setzte sorgen dann mache ich das mal
eben hier ganz provisorisch mal eben so
und dann lasst ihr noch mal ganz kurz
runter fallen
ihr seht die repeater verschwinden
einfach keine dran herlaufen ich kann
drunter gucken da ist kein repeater die
ganzen teile sind quasi einfach spurlos
verschwunden
jetzt denkt sich wieder die halbe
weltbevölkerung herüber müsste ein black
screen jahr leute wir sind beinahe eines
vollen geräusch angekommen das letzte
geheimnisvolle geräusche wurde nur von
einer person erkannt und zwar der
kommentar der grat eingeblendet wird es
ist eine filmklappe die ich so
zugeschlagen habe ich habe die gerade
nicht hier liegen also ich kann nicht
normal zeigen allerdings dass neue
geräusch was ihr mir ab jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben können und
eventuell der der als erstes das
geschrieben hat das was richtig ist wird
in der nächsten folge erwähnt ist das
hier so freunde das geräusch und jetzt
auch viel spaß weiter in meinem video
der dritte weg wurde mit zugesendet von
supra wonder danke an dich ist auch sehr
cool
und zwar habe ich mir hier schon ein
schweinchen geholt ich habe mir mal ganz
kurz hierfür das manchmal zu essen also
mit karotten route also hier das scheint
ich kann jetzt ein bisschen das essen
hier dafür dass sie hier das erste mal
in einer mine shafter disney gibt sich
schon gut so gut geht es gut naja egal
ich hatte jedenfalls ein kleines
schweinchen hab das einfach mal in
sonnen
moore reingedrängt jetzt ist es in
dieser lore und das geile ist ich mache
das ganze jetzt mal ganz kurz drauf ich
wollte nur bevor ich das hier
vorbereitet dass das ganze teil die
nicht ja nicht dass das schweinchen auf
einmal durchbrennen mit meinem kater und
zwar kann ich mich einfach hier so drauf
setzt und wenn ich jetzt ganz normal in
die richtungen drücke steuert sich
martin jeweils andere riecht und es ist
egal ob ich da eine karotte route nehmen
oder nicht ich kann wenn ich in einem in
einem schweinchen in dem ein kart sitze
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise ich drücke
jetzt mal nach hinten dann vereint nach
vorn ich drückt man nach rechts dann
nach links aber ich kann mich auf jeden
fall damit fortbewegen jetzt ist zwar
sehr sehr langsam aber es funktioniert
und das ist unglaublich und das macht
ungewisses mario kart feeling ich komme
damit allerdings gar keine blöcke hoch
das sieht es schon seht ihr schon ich
komme ich mal einen halben lockt damit
hoch aber ich kann damit reiht natürlich
ist es ein bisschen cooler und ein
bisschen angenehmer wenn ich das ganze
wenn ich das ganze so mache dann läuft
das ganze ein bisschen vernünftiger wenn
sich das schweinchen jemand kriegen
würde
hallo kollege aber ich denke ihr wisst
was ihr euch zeigen wollte und es
funktioniert dass man einen quasi man
hat so ein auto in minecraft dadurch der
vierte und letzte weg wurde mir
zugesendet von
schweins kreativ crazy name und zwar
wenn ich mir einen zaun nehme kann nicht
in dem zaun verschwinden und zwar ich
kann das so machen die mich einfach die
ein tief in ihr müsst genau in die mitte
schauen
hier ist das relativ egal hier kann ich
auch so springen dann bin ich im zaun
drin also ich muß geruch springen und
dann während ich hochspringer setzen ich
kann auch schon so egal wie spät ich den
setzte nur halt nicht erst wenn ich
wieder hier bin wir dann geht's nicht
allerdings wenn ich hier zum beispiel
stehe ich oben drauf und ich stehe hier
am rand des blogs und ich mache so dann
geht der blogger halt in die mittel
dieser zaun
wenn ich allerdings mich genau die mitte
stelle so nett war dann lande ich in dem
zaun drin und dann stehe ich quasi in
dem zaun egal wie oft ich springe egal
was ich hier mache ich stehe in dem
sound bis ich quasi so rausgehen und
dann kann ich nicht wieder rein und
backe ich nämlich nur noch darum wenn
ich dagegen laufe so allerdings wenn ich
quasi im loch bildern verbindet sich
derzeit mit allen ecken das heißt ich
kann damit in einen zaun reingehen und
das ganze ist auf jeden fall ein relativ
cool effect und danke an die schweiz
gilt dass das funktioniert so freundlich
wird er noch sagen ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen ich hoffe auch das geräusch
erkannt was in dieser folge wieder
einmal vorgekommen ist wenn ja schreibt
in die kommentare spend es oft rein wie
nur wollt weil dadurch ist die chance
größer dass ihr quasi beim nächsten
fakes video mit erwähnt werden zweiter
kontraste gmail.com davon lebt die serie
das sind nur euro effekt genannt werden
deswegen erwähne ich euch auch immer als
kleiner ansporn aus dem effekt zu senden
da werden richtig geile sache eingesetzt
wie zum beispiel das mit dem ein kart
hierbei echt mega cool und dann würde
ich sagen meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat bitte lasst doch ein
mag ich das vergessen die meisten immer
das ist wirklich einfach so ein zeichen
wenn euch die serie gefällt dann zeigt
es mir mit merklichen haben wir die
frage nach den wunderschönen tag